this morning the Supreme Court hears a
case pitting Free Speech against gay
rights a Christian website designer is
challenging a Colorado law that requires
her to create wedding websites for
same-sex couples even though she opposes
same-sex marriage Jan Crawford is
outside the Supreme Court Jan good
morning so what would we hear today
well good morning Nate you know this
case really raises interesting questions
for artists and designers who might be
asked to create messages they disagree
with so it's kind of pitting the First
Amendment against anti-discrimination
law now Colorado website designer Lori
Smith says she'll help any client with
their work or their branding but she
won't design a website that will
contradict her Christian religious
beliefs and that includes creating
websites for same-sex Weddings But that
refusal would violate Colorado's
anti-discrimination law which would
require her to design websites for all
couples she says the government can't
make her create messages that that would
violate Her First Amendment rights now
State Attorney General Phil Weiser says
the law is about making sure lgbtq
people are treated equally so that you
know businesses can't just turn them
away now the court had a similar case
five years ago involving a baker he won
that case but narrowly the justices
didn't take up these bigger First
Amendment issues so now it's back before
this newly conservative of Supreme Court
Gail
Jan thank you very much